I'm Tyler and I'm a disciple of more
time this is your at-home Whiteside core
workout okay so we've got a multi core
workout in store for you today we are
going to be doing a bunch different
things with this whole area of your body
right so what do we what are we starting
off with today kind of a plank so let's
drop down and come down on one knee
okay I'm gonna poking it down I'm gonna
come down I'm gonna lay all the way flat
okay so what we're gonna do is going to
go from a claim to a push-up position
now when I come from this position
instead of trying to just pop up on my
feet okay I'm literally going to kind of
push back on my hands push back on my
toes to where I come back to now I'm in
this position then I'm going to shift my
body weight over one hand down and press
up other hand down and if you notice I
have my hands down in front of me and
not out of further out in front of me
I'm really putting pressure on my
rotator cuff it's not only want to do
you're squeezing your stomach keeping
your body as straight as possible
I'm not rounded out back to the elbow
here and from here I'm gonna push off my
toes push forward and then go down flat
so here we go go ahead laid out nice and
flat good feet go all the way out behind
you
we want our toes to be down so your feet
gonna be flat behind you like this go
ahead and push up and down good if you
want to make it a little more advanced
you can do a push-up from here okay you
can do it by a timeframe or you can do a
buy it number you can say okay I'm gonna
do it for a minute or I'm gonna do 20
depending on your fitness level and what
you want to do now we can just go ahead
and switch another one to my other
favorite okay
I'm gonna sit back on my butt I'm gonna
keep my chest out okay I'm not gonna
round my back down okay
I'm gonna bring my feet off the ground
go ahead just like this and what I'm
gonna do is push my feet straight back
out bring back in and grab my knees good
now try to push your feet up a little
higher and look up just like that
the end about right there and back in
good and you're using your core and your
abs just to decelerate and slow your
body down when you to that position you
feel that right it more at least up now
last one you got the hold for ten
seconds
deep breath stay right there hold ten
nine and pray good job now we're gonna
go ahead and switch it out to another
one there's more yes I like to call
these Superman so I have my hands in
front of me I have my feet behind me all
I'm gonna do is when you come up and I'm
gonna count for two seconds ready go up
one two and then them more in shape you
get the longer one you can hold it here
we go come up and down remember
we're really work on squeezing your
midsection okay
feel your hamstrings your legs
everything squeeze up nice and tight
good job alright guys so to recap on
this white tie core workout we started
off with the lay down to plank to
push-up position
we then did the leg press stabilized leg
presses so you're sitting on your butt
and then we finished up with the
Superman's through those till your form
really gets bad I can be a number like
five ten reps it can be omitted it can
be ten minutes again that number will
increase as your strength increases and
trust me guys this is a core intensive
great routine right here Tyler thank you
so much Bob man good job excellent work
appreciate it
make sure to subscribe so you don't miss
out on any other fighting weight
episodes